Ever since I read the book “In
Praise of Shadows”,
I've always had this image of Japan.
But when I visited it
for the first time in August,
it wasn't quite what I expected.
Even the places that Jun’ichirō Tanizaki
beautifully describes in his book,
it was almost impossible
to experience them as they were intended.
As an architect trying to identify
my own philosophy on design, I felt myself
desperately trying to cling to this idea
of this mysterious place.
But every time I tried to reach it,
it kept getting away from me.
Was I too late?
Does my idea of Japan still exist?
I decided to travel to a place
where space, sound
and time are perceived
in a completely different way.
A place where people embrace
and craft the shadows.
Japan.
a portion of this video
sponsored by Fiverr.
This is the Sayama pond
about an hour
and a half away from the heart of Osaka.
And we came here hoping to experience
something different.
It's Japan's oldest reservoir
dating back to the seventh century.
And for generations, the water
from this pond nurtured the land
and sustained the communities.
In the Shintoist or animist traditions
that's rooted in Japanese
culture, places like this
aren't just resources or landscapes.
They're the dwelling places of the spirits
who protect the land.
And you can feel this reverence
for nature at the Sayamaike Museum,
which was designed by the Pritzker
Prize winning architect Tadao Ando.
The museum covers
the history of Japan's flood
control measures and irrigation systems.
But it's a lot more than that.
Standing there I felt small,
like I was being swallowed
by the presence of something grand.
Simple geometries
create a sense of visual harmony.
And all of this made me pause.
There's rituals twice
every hour for 5 minutes.
There's a waterfall that you can walk
under.
A little further down.
There's a circular courtyard,
and walking up the length of the ramp,
as you circle around the geometry,
it slows down your pace
before entering the museum,
just like a medieval labyrinth,
which purposely slows you down
by taking the long route.
When you finally enter the museum,
you're faced with a monumental structure.
It's a segment
from the old bank of the pond.
And as you walk down this long ramp,
You can almost feel
the history
embedded in each layer of the sediment.
This determines
the height of the building.
Meaning the building
is the exact depth of the pond,
creating the symbolic connection.
Then there's the natural light,
which is celebrated and made more
beautiful by putting it against concrete
and creating a deep shadow around it.
When Jun’ichirō Tanizaki describes
the shadows in traditional
Japanese esthetics, he's
talking about this:
The layered glow of the shoji screen,
the subtle
soft daylight that enters through the deep
eaves of a Japanese roof.
But Tadao Ando, he takes this
into a whole new dimension.
Tadao Ando
was actually a self-trained architect,
and in 1964, when he was just 24 years
old, he traveled to Rome and visited
the Pantheon.
There
he found a very different kind of light
than the one that's praised in his home
country.
The single central cut out in the Pantheon
created this dramatic gesture.
It's stark.
And in certain moments,
it cuts through the space like a knife.
Apparently, this was the moment
he decided to become an architect.
Throughout our trip,
we visited a lot of Tadao
Ando's buildings.
And I think what's really unique
about his architecture is how he merges
the nuanced Japanese shadow with a bold,
almost theatrical kind of light.
He said “the light becomes glorious only
when it's lit against the background
of the deepest darkness.” In his spaces.,
even the gentlest, most restrained
daylight becomes a spectacle, and it's
sculpts the concrete with a deep shadow.
And for brief moments of the day,
a slit of light comes in, that breaks
the concrete surface,
and intensifying the spatial depth.
And in
these moments, time becomes tangible.
But the more time I spent in Japan,
I realized this obsession with shadows...
...It's not just about what we see
or even understand with logic.
(whispering)
This is St Mary's Cathedral in Tokyo
by Kenzo Tange.
It reminds me of something that was made
not by humans, but crafted by the immense
force of nature.
Sitting here I felt heavy and weightless
at the same time.
There's a concept in Japanese esthetics.
“Yūgen”.
it comes from Zen Buddhism and speaks
to a profound, mysterious sense of beauty
of the universe...
...and
also the sad beauty of human suffering.
At St Mary's Cathedral
there's an atmosphere
that's both awe-inspiring and enigmatic.
It really does
give you the sense of an unknowable beauty
that's profound but remains just beyond
the grasp of full comprehension.
But actually this “feeling” might
just be a deliberate design choice
by Kenzo Tange, trying to avoid
any obvious symbolism at the cathedral.
If you look at the building
from an aerial view,
you will see that
the window openings form a cross.
But unless you can a fly, most of us will
never see the building from this angle.
You can only feel the presence
of the cross
as two lines of light
illuminating the space.
He also blurs
the line between walls and ceiling,
creating a single continuous form
that challenge our sense of boundaries.
This also creates
a very strong perspective and depth,
making the Cathedral seem grander
than it really is.
The textures add to this illusion
and it reminds you of something that
you would find in nature.
What was I saying?
日本の建築は本当に素晴ら しかったです。
What?
are you okay?
え、私、日本語を話しているの？
Ahh,
Ahh, that’s Miho from our sponsor
Ahh, hi Miho!
We hired Miho and Eito from Fiverr to
translate and dub this video in Japanese.
Fiverr is a great platform
where you can find professionals
from all over the world,
from graphic design, video production,
marketing and creative writing.
It's virtually impossible
not to find what you're looking for
in such a great community.
And Fiverr gives you
all the tools to get the job done,
even if you have a really small budget.
In fact, it was super easy
to work with Miho and Eito
and the whole process was super fast.
So whatever creative project
you have in your mind,
you can get it done with Fiverr.
Visit Fiverr dot co.
That's C-O slash DAMILEE and use code
DAMILEE to get a 10% discount
on your next project.
Thanks again,
Miho and EIto for helping us out.
Zenbo Seinei
is a meditation retreat in Awaji island
designed by Shigeru Ban.
And here I experience some of these ideas
in a totally different light.
It's a 100 meter long timber structure
built
with a combination of pine, cedar
and other timbers from Japan.
In fact, the whole place had this
lingering scent of Japanese cedar.
It's respectfully integrated
into the landscape,
aligning with a mountain ridge
rather than sitting above it.
And almost hovering over the forest,
minimizing its footprint.
And it creates this
delicate balance of nature and manmade.
This was my very first meditation retreat,
but I have practiced meditation
on and off for a lot of years.
But this was a whole new experience
from my practice at home.
It wasn't just about clearing the mind.
It was about deepening the sensory
experience and my connection to nature.
Zen Buddhism is about a direct
experiential understanding
through meditation and mindfulness.
And being present.
it's about a connection with the ordinary
parts of life and with nature.
So I think a lot of Japanese
designs are simple
and understated,
but it highlights the things around us.
In Tadao Ando’s spaces,
he highlights the trees or the sky
or the people by framing them
and turning them into artworks.
Here we highlight nature
using a simple flat roof
and creating this steady, repetitive
rhythm with wood beams and columns.
The central platform steps
up, stepping back from the glass railing.
So when you're sitting on the platform,
you get an almost unobstructed view
of the horizon.
Sitting here...
...It's kind of a sensory delight,
and it made the meditation practice
almost effortless.
I could feel the breeze,
the rustling of the leaves,
the subtle scent of the forest,
the rhythmic humming of the cicadas.
something that I noticed
was how Japanese
people were so light on their feet.
Even the guys, they walked like this,
landing on the balls of their feet.
Because in a wood building like this,
and also probably in traditional
Japanese buildings,
if you're walking with the heels first,
you can hear that sound
in the entire space...
...and you feel extremely intrusive.
And this was actually
a bit of a challenge for me,
which is funny because my favorite
part of the whole experience
was actually the walking meditation.
As I focus on just walking,
I was surprised to feel the texture
of the wood on my feet
and the subtle temperature differences
in the part of the floor
that were shaded by the columns.
But it's not just the meditation,
the whole building
is essentially one long linear procession.
And as you walk down the long halls
or the meditation platform,
the rhythm of the structure helps
you slow down your pace.
There's a Japanese concept, Ma.
It's the space between elements, the time
between the beginning and the end.
It's the gap, the space, or the pause.
But Ma is not simply an absence,
but an active presence
that shapes our experiences.
And this concept captures
my experience here at Zenbo Seinei.
Although I came here to pause,
my experience
was actually quite full.
We’ve visited
a lot of different places in Japan.
But there was one place
that was a testament
to some of these concepts
we're talking about.
But the trip to this building
was not easy.
It was about three and a half hours
transit from Awaji Island
to this small port town
and another ferry to the island.
All of this for this one building.
It started raining on our ferry
and it continued to rain
as we made our way up the hill.
Walking up, we could see the beautiful,
lush landscape, and a change in the air.
once we reached the site, there was this
winding path through different landscapes
and soundscapes with a cool ocean breeze
coming from the left.
At the end of the path is a large,
monolithic concrete dome
sitting in the landscape.
And when I
entered,
the first thing I noticed is the silence.
And then a strange sound
echoing in the space.
Then you see that
everyone is kind of looking
at the floor, either
standing around or sitting down.
At first I thought the pool of water on
the ground was from the rain.
And some of it
definitely was because there were
two large openings open to the air.
but when I look closer, I notice that
the small droplets of water were moving,
trickling down ever so slowly,
combining with other droplets
into these tiny holes in the concrete,
making a sound
like this.
I, along
with dozens of other people,
sat there for hours.
And slowly
you start to notice more and more details.
I noticed that the space seemed to capture
sound even from a distance.
For example, I noticed that a crow
flew overhead making this *crow sound
but you could hear the sound echo
inside the dome.
There were two large openings,
one facing the forest and one
facing the sky,
which allowed the wind to funnel through.
When the wind blew, the leaves
would rustle I could feel the wind
brushing against me and a piece of string
which were hung on either holes
would float ever so gently in the wind.
This might sound like
an oversimplification,
but there is a fundamental difference
between Western philosophy and Eastern
philosophy, Western culture is rooted
in the enlightenment's ideals of reason
and clarity, and light has become
a symbol of knowledge and progress.
So, don't like shadows.
We try to get as much light as possible.
But Eastern culture is rooted in Shinto
and Buddhist philosophies,
where they appreciate the ephemeral
and the subtle.
And more than any other eastern country,
I think Japan has been able to preserve
and refine this into their design
philosophy,
which is why when you visit
a lot of their cities, you'll see this
beautiful, seamless connection
between the old and the new.
The problem is in today's visual culture
driven by the algorithm,
there's not a lot of room for nuance.
We want the quick reward.
We want the money shots.
We want the maximum impact
in the shortest amount of time possible.
And I guess that's
also kind of the irony of this video.
I'm describing verbally and visually
what you should be experiencing
with your whole body
over an extended period of time.
So, I would still highly recommend
you check out some of these places
for yourself.
If you want the full travel
itinerary of the buildings that we visited
and how we got there, we have created
a PDF that you can download
and I'll link it in the description.
my challenge to you...
...describe a place that's stuck
in your mind for whatever reason.
Try to be as detailed as possible.
What did you see? What did you hear?
What did you feel?
You can leave your
responses in the comments.